we have not seen you do this sort of  stuff before and be that kind of woman  kind of very focused went violent and  did but I heard you in and if you say  that your family will recognize this  version but the action stuff gives you  right you know writing that huge  motorcycle and the jumping around the  big fights so how much of that did you  do or what were you kind of up for at  all I mean if I'd had if time wasn't an  issue I would have learned to ride a  motorcycle and being short and stuff but  they were like no so I had three stunt  doubles but I did all all the fights I  loved I loved doing the fights had you  ever done that before you trained like  that mrs. no I sort of pretty I've  strangled a couple of people in some  films but that's like a one that happens  one you had to do continuous kind of  like 15 minutes you're remembering a  fight  [Laughter]  it's really cool  [Music]